we've got multiple pilots one more
one-night-only Joe just got dumped I got
a box for that and of course lots of
drama good luck tonight thank you yeah
so grab your glass grab your wine we're
here to recap The Bachelorette premiere
it's time for roses and Rosie you guys
i'm lauren zima and Hanna's Bachelorette
premiere is here oh my gosh you guys I
am so excited for Hanna season of The
Bachelorette that look what I got
look what I got look what I got it's a
blind bottle opener and it's rose it's
rose rose de rose gold why am I thinking
out with let's top yourself oh my god
and I have my favorite bottle of wine
for the premiere the brand which shall
not be named because they don't sponsor
us but you can probably guess what
bottle it is based on the shape of it is
very signature so let's get to it
some people cut the foil off of their
wine when they're gonna open it I don't
I see drill right through it you got a
stream line we got stuff to do
we got Bachelorette premieres to talk
about what did you guys think I thought
it was great super fun wait wait
oh that's a good sound sound also look
at me wine glass this is soup of the day
because it's like if you like every day
trick about drinking every day please
drink responsibly okay you guys we are
going to go over Hannah Brown's season
premiere of course tell me what you
thought of it overall in the comments
below did it live up to your
expectations was she the boost we all
thought she was gonna be
and a quick shameless plug head to et
online calm because they have interviews
with Hannah and Chris Harrison about the
premiere bring on now I should note we
are going to be giving kind of a
highlight reel of these guys and the
premiere moments because you guys we can
talk about all of them it's too many
guys see you guys okay I can't get into
like we'd vote we don't need to know all
of them we won't know them after like
two weeks from now anyway unless we have
another grocery store Joe on our hands
but we're gonna get into all that let's
start out with a drink tells like home
so our take away from our back to Hannah
segment is that Hannah's big struggle is
that she is afraid not being perfect I
was struggling to be perfect let's
remember that because I think it's
foreshadowing for the season it's
critical okay the greatest fear thing is
always a thing then we move into the
intro packages of the guys overall
101-80 these guys are so much better
looking on camera then they where it's
most horrible teal background photos
which the lighting i five questions
about that there's better photos up on
abc's site now but anyway butter on
camera and from a general contractor on
the airline pilot portfolio manager
district sales manager
it's great cheers to a real job every
time you see one please drink
responsibly hmm okay first up Tyler okay
maybe we didn't start so strong because
we had a flub right we kidding
I'm 26 years old Tyler is saying out
loud I'm 26 and on screen it says he's
25
now this flood isn't it Game of Thrones
a Starbucks cup level but I mean it's
it's just back
so Tyler's in his mid 20s and he is a
project manager construction worker man
I'm a general contractor whatever I
don't care
he's got a job he's gainfully employed
and he loves to dance
cheers to Tyler I love a guy who dances
drink every time Tyler had a fun dance
move he set me and Kevin Bacon our
offspring when it comes to dancing Kevin
Bacon awake offspring when it comes to
dancing I don't know about Tyler smarts
or TBD I think he might have met
siblings but whatever I guess offspring
are siblings athira board from the same
pants
and again love is moobs love his mousse
he doesn't man boobs he has the opposite
drink for every one of Tyler's abs we're
gonna go through this whole bottle
aren't we drink responsibly and with a
friend I'm home JC's here ok anyway
we'll see more Simulator 2 then Peters
intro package Peter is a pile in Berlin
pellets and another good looking guy and
he seems so casual and cute in his
little bomber jacket his interview he
seems nice easy genuine he talks about
his family you guys is this my new Peter
what if I'm not ready
am i saying goodbye to Peter crafts I
never thought I'd see the day but I'm
glad it has come you know get across
with me on the franchise anymore my bye
bye all the best this is the new Peter a
pilot Peter a love pilot Peter let's fly
away let's take off let's land
successfully and in the new place we're
a new chapter and a new Peter hmm
welcome to my city Dallas next up Mike
gave me hitch vibes he talked about his
big ears he made a joke about his dating
life okay talking home now
I don't know what his job was numbers
and he walked around talking on a phone
I don't know get an office Mike but he
seemed nice and I liked Mike hi I'm Jill
bar Santo and I sell boxes Joe the box
guy I love Joe the box guy you know he
had his brand figured out didn't he then
I gotta give him credit for that you're
gonna go on this show with a goal and
that goal is to promote your box company
remember you know what you nailed it
you're gonna put your junk in a box I
got that and the junk too and that I was
like is this the new grocery store Joe
both from Chicago both a very clear job
where we lose Joe the Box skyknight one
well we see him on Dancing with the
Stars I hope not okay but he seemed
great
from Chicago too so all my love to Joe
so my timing on that I was like anyway
[Music]
I'm 24 and I live in Gainesville Georgia
next up Luke from Gainesville Oh Luke P
now guys we've seen Luke peep screaming
in the promo for this season the trailer
for the whole season so it's hard to not
view him through that lens isn't it like
I just hear the screen not when I see
him in the scenes gonna mess it up I
hear the screams wanna see any mystery
here the screen
oh my dreams my nightmares okay is an
import-export manager I don't know what
that means but he is importing muscles
and exporting sweat on an extreme level
throughout this intro package and let me
talk to God in the shower I had
encounters dog I was in the shower and
God was speaking to me it's great I
don't talk to God I think I believe in
what you want to believe in like live
your life for a higher power that's
great but I just didn't expect him to
stay in the shower but you know maybe
he's spending a lot of time there
because he's working out so much so he's
always showering so it was just an odd
thing on when that pronto happened
hey just packing here look my coupon
these then that baby was helping him
pack and it just looked like that baby
was like slides down [ __ ] that baby up I
don't know the baby was probably fine I
don't know much about how babies work
let's be honest I'm not hanging out with
them all the time
[Music]
okay and now we are at the mansion
what's your greatest fear here now we've
learned an additional greatest fear of
Hanna's that someone won't be as real
with her as she's being with them I'm
gonna be real so somebody's not going to
equally be as girl with me I guess and
we're getting our limo entrances and
meet Garrett's
okay Garrett's from Birmingham so
Garrett give a nice little intro about
being a golf pro there's gonna be a lot
of people tonight yes maybe a few bogeys
and you gave some golf puns and you know
I want to be your hole-in-one I'll
appreciate a pun over making me play
that sport with you you know an amazing
okay Mike bruised even more than he's
hit drink every time Mike seems like
hitch begin each day as if it were on
purpose cuz he gets out of the limo and
he kind of gives her this these like
rules to live by like he's got five C's
that's all kind of have like the five
seas okay but I live by I remember what
they were but it just seemed like a
hitch thing to me like if and if I had
my five C you'll be calm down you crazy
woman you're coming off like a cuckoo
bird
what would your 5c speak then we're
gonna meet Jed and Jed is a
singer-songwriter there's always one and
he seems sweet I was surprised he didn't
sing walking up in his intro but don't
worry don't worry he's staying inside
the pitch here by my side
you knew he wasn't gonna get there night
one without it okay meet Dylan Dylan is
wearing a full white tux and he looks
like he's from the year 1955 and I'm
really not sure about it and Dylan
promises to be authentic every step of
the way and a promise like that rings
alarm bells to me for sure I don't mean
I don't know just explain the tux Dylan
look like a [ __ ] Weiner okay Dylan I
appreciate the old-school glam but I
don't know what it's doing here there
okay
how you guys doing out the crowd all
right that is brought in the wrong time
I think I'm good at that I'm not damn I
am I good at that JC he has to support
me we work together okay then a name we
won't forget Jean Paul Jones saved up on
James
three times fast Joe Gentz don't
[ __ ] jump on check you guys I love
John Paul Jones John Paul Jones
I loved him just from his picture
because it gets thing that he looks like
a like Revolutionary War soldier his
skin is creamy pale he's got this long
hair look he looks like he belongs in a
war movie and then to hear him speak
tonight he's actually kind of like a
surfer bro my friends call me John Paul
Jones
she's like my name's John Paul Jones
Matt you can call me John Paul Jones I
don't know I love him I think he's gonna
be a coop paradise my prediction math
teacher Brian well he seems pretty
nervous laughing a lot drink every time
you nervous laughs
[Laughter]
when I heard that you're gonna be the
Bachelorette I was so excited you just
have this awesome personality then we
had Scott a software sales exact oh my
god this is the job that never dies on
the bachelorettes and Scott is gonna die
in a way though more to come on that
Mateo
he is cute and nice but all I can
remember is that his cast bio revealed
that he's a sperm donor
I think he's fathered over a hundred
children and I think one oh can someone
honestly Tommy if someone has fathered
like a hundred kids how is it ensured
that those kids don't accidentally date
each other out in the world without
knowing that they're half siblings I'm
really wondering this and is incest on
my mind because the Game of Thrones yes
sorry Game of Thrones reference some of
you like them quick shout out to the
guys you brought snacks one of them
brought some champagne one brought pizza
good for you who's bringing a snack
don't bring me a sport bring me a snack
okay Luke entrance Oh
do you guys ever have to pause when
something so awkward it's like you
become a child again and you can't
handle the awkwardness and the tension
and you just like you're like come on I
know that's how I felt during Luke's
entrance Luke I get it he was being a
beast for Hannah beast but again knowing
that later on we're going to see him
scream in another man's face towering
over him and seeing him screaming on top
of that car
I was I was uncomfortable I was
uncomfortable
what did you guys think of it piano was
in you know and she did remember Luke's
name for meeting him at a afar and that
makes me think Anna's kind of into Luke
from the season trailer does look like
he sticks around for a minute so let me
know at this point I wrote down tired of
meeting guys now I was I was but then oh
we don't have to meet a guy we've got a
piece of farming equipment
tractor showed up drink for every time
we get a piece of equipment no way are
you serious right now
I would drive out in a wine barrel I was
rolling me out and there's wine in it
and I'm drinking it as a boy okay oh my
god another pilot drink for every pilot
and chasin his paper airplane was cute
it was but I was thinking why wouldn't
he come in his uniform and then bumper
Peter showed up in his uniform pilot
Peter guys he's our new man I think so I
loved looking at him in Hannah next to
each other they looked like a movie
literally an officer and a lady from the
world that movie was called an officer
and a gentleman my hand is a beast but
she's a woman anyway whatever they
looked like old Hollywood glamour
gorgeousness and Peter one-up chasin
with the paper airplane he's gave her
his actual wings mm-hmm
cheers to Peter I almost wore my uniform
I almost came into my uniform tonight
you're positive that's what you're
thinking just the effort I want to say
first off thank you I'm just really
thankful that you all decided to say yes
to taking this chance with me Hannah of
course gives the traditional toast to
kick things off because thank God we are
finally done and throwing everyone and
Hannah good job with the toes I don't
want perfect I want real a big
turnaround from that first one-on-one
with Colton she did a great job what did
you think of her toast let me know yes
another red flag with lewd you guys he
grabs her steals hood for the first time
in the night which kind of like always
makes someone an enemy whether they're a
great person or not everybody's gonna
like hate on that person but here's what
he told her he said she was the most
beautiful girl he'd ever seen
are you the most
hi guys and Hanna's beautiful don't get
me wrong but if a guy tells me that I'm
like really really have you seen Cindy
Crawford have you taken a look that Gigi
Hadid I'm not out here trying to be a
supermodel
so I don't believe you so don't lie to
me and Hanna wants unreal she is set
back so red flags throw out Scott my own
hair is through struggle and I still
struggle with it tell me about that huge
red flags for Luke but points to hitch
Mike Mike asked Hannah questions about
herself and that was always a good sign
to me when on night one the guys not
just talking talking talking about
himself he's asking the woman questions
about her good job Mike
and drink for every kiss cam got a kiss
and Connor got a kiss and Luke got a
kiss we'll talk more about that later
but for now it's just an opportunity to
drink four kisses I finish that
just a casual Monday soup of the Monday
okay stop putting things on your face
points now Demi and Katie are here
they're in the van we knew that this was
gonna happen they're Hannah's angels
keeping an eye out for things with
Hannah but here's the thing they didn't
really see anything on that night that
they had to tell Hannah about it
they're big information all came from
someone telling Demi earlier that day
earlier today someone reach out to me on
social media saying that what did the
guys here has a girlfriend that a
contestant had a girlfriend I don't
believe it I'm sorry I don't I'm here
for the show I love it but I it just
seems to me that probably the producers
found out about that somehow and Demi is
gonna deliver this information I mean
she got a message earlier that day I
don't believe it's sorry by the way
cheers - Demi from being in what looked
like PJ's shorts just comfy that's a
long night I'm gonna show up in a
sweater in PJs shorts - oh my god that's
him that's the guy with the girlfriend
so Scott is the guy who had the
girlfriend and Scott is going on on to
Han about his expensive tastes and
sounding like total douche I knew you're
nervous
coming in today Wow it might be because
you have a girlfriend I don't have a
girlfriend
so here confronts cotton at first I'm
like no baby Scott doesn't have the
worst point in the world like I mean has
just come off of dating Colton I've
heard that you do have a girlfriend okay
that you talked to her on Monday but
then we find out that he was like still
dating this girl as a one day Scott oh
god don't you think I just met you so
like I have no idea how it was gonna go
I had no idea
kept your girlfriend back at home just
to be safe what did you guys think was
Hannah right to send Scott home I
thought so come and I love the way she
walked him out she kept going come on
come on
it's a Cepheid Scott all right so Luke P
gets the first impression rose we talked
to Hannah and Chris Harrison about the
bachelorettes winding up with their
first impression Rose picks for the past
several season those interviews are up
at easy online calm shameless plug what
do you guys think will Hannah end up
with Luke P she remembered him from afar
she gave him the first impression rose
and she kissed him for a long time drink
for that whole [ __ ]
[Applause]
yeah by the way guys some of you go in
the comments and you put spoilers in
there please don't do that no no no
we're all watching the show together
okay
PSA for the whole season no spoilers in
comments thank you we are reviewing not
revealing okay all right so the guys we
have sent home are Ryan and Matt Donald
and Thomas the basketball player and
chasten the pilot only room for one
pilot in this guy I guess and Joe the
fog sky Oh another one-night-only Joe
from Chicago what do you guys think is
Joe the Box guy the new grocery store
Joe I don't think so you can only be the
one night wonder one time streak every
time I'm saying what jeez please drink
responsibly
okay that's gonna be all for today
everybody overall again what did you
think of the premiere I simply loved it
I thought Hanna nailed it I also think
these guys overall have some good looks
have some good jobs have some good drama
up ahead so I'm in Chris Harrison told
me in our interview that it was the most
quote man drama that he's seen in a
while so get ready buckle up
always wear your seat belt why don't
people wear their seat belts Lauren
don't digress everybody I love you all
so much I'm so so so happy and excited
to start this season of The Bachelorette
and also I'm sorry one last shameless
plug I am on cameo so if you would like
a message from me for any reason at all
head on over to cameo and I will make it
simply performative I'm tipsy response
we love you guys
we'll be here every Tuesday for rows and
rows a and every Tuesday morning we will
recap Monday night's episode with a
guest yes yes yes yes yes over on et
live at 10:00 a.m. Pacific so don't miss
it
you guys there's always got to be
[Music]
that's right and so today JC's here
little song for Anna watch the vessel
red hand is pretty cool but there were
lots of guys slinging in the mouth like
fools and smiles worth every mom talking
about boxes couple pilots - what's a
girl like Hannah sorry
woman supposed to do
[Music]
Wow first impression rose
my rule
[Music]